I realize that we're running a bit out
of time so I'll keep this shorter than
than scheduled this event and thank you
very much for inviting me because it is
a truly important topic and this event
shows the tremendous ambition of the
industry to bring consumers and
businesses connectivity to the it to the
highest quality network possible the
Netherlands Authority for consumers and
market is a multifunctional authority we
are a competition Authority we are a
telecoms authority an Energy Authority a
consumer protection authority and you
may call it a court play authority as it
telecoms authority and in that capacity
I'm standing here before you the ACMs
aim is to contribute to a
well-functioning market leading to
innovative services and at competitive
prices for end-users and for us
competition is key to achieving that aim
because we strongly believe that
competition leads to investments and
investments lead to connectivity now
let's turn to competition and look at
some of their figures because there are
a few things that worried us as a
telecoms regulator in the Netherlands
and that were decreasing investments
decreasing sharing and increasing prices
if you look at the first slide you see
that unfortunately over the past few
years we witnessed less rather than more
investment in broadband in the
Netherlands and this figure represents
the total cumulative amount of
investments in fixed networks of all
major telecom operators in the
Netherlands as you can see there has
been a significant decline over the past
few years and on the second slide
that's this slide you can see the decree
in the additional numbers homes passed
by fiber and this shows also
specifically how much investments in
fiber have decreased over the past few
years in addition to this we also saw
churn decrease and churn as was well
known is one of the indicators for us
for competition less churn is a warning
signal that there may be less
competition in the market and finally
what we saw is a development of retail
prices for fixed access for bundled
services where you see over the past
years the the prices for bundles
increasing so in summary we we saw
investments decrease we saw churn
decrease and we saw prices increase and
this concerned us and this brings us to
the market intervention that that we did
a few months ago what do we do we tried
a measure to stimulate competition and
more investments and among other things
we decided to improve network access to
the two fixed networks in the
Netherlands that of KPN and that of
Vodafone ziggo so what did we do
first we analyzed the market we looked
at the market and so two networks with a
I would say comfortable 40 to 45 percent
market share and with reduced figures
and increased prices we saw a decrease I
repeat a decrease in infrastructure
investments and that market how we
viewed it was slowly but steadily or
maybe on the verge of developing into a
quiet duopoly and that concerned us and
that concern we addressed by adopting
our new wholesale fixed access decision
that decision is currently under appeal
but we strongly believe that we we can
we will win
withstand judicial scrutiny and that we
will prevail also in court and our
decision describes the unique situation
of joint dominance in the Netherlands
between on the one hand
KPN and on the other hand Vodafone's ago
and that's a fairly unique situation in
Europe so what we did with our decision
is we forced both networks to open up to
wholesale competition and to third
parties by forcing photophone ziggo to
open up its network we are ensuring that
competing service providers have the
choice between to basically wholesale
networks that of Vodafone and that of
kpn on this slide you see the Dutch
telecoms landscape on the left hand uck
PN's practically full covering copper
network on the second slide you see
Vodafone Z goes coax network which is
covering at this moment about 90 percent
of the households in the Netherlands and
on the third slide on the third box on
your right hand you see the chart of the
fiber-to-the-home
networks in the Netherlands and what is
striking is that for those of you who
are not fully aware of the geography
geography of the Netherlands on the
right hand side is more relatively more
rural than the left hand side so
contrary to kind of an intuition in the
Netherlands you see that there is
actually more investment in fiber in
rural areas than in the urban areas and
what we aim with our decision or
wholesale access decision is to improve
and incentivize the parties to roll out
fiber in the light pink areas the more
urban areas in the Netherlands so
opening up access to the fixed network
of Vodafone ziggo ensures that kpn is no
longer the only nationwide network open
to third parties and this will create in
our opinion for the first time
infrastructure competition at
so level between kpn and Vodafone ziggo
and as a result it will lead to more
investments in our decision we've also
taken measures to make fiber investments
easier so where fiber is deployed by K
by K P n regulated access to the copper
network is withdrawn and this means that
there are no double network expenses for
KP n in addition we made access to
Vodafone Z goes Network conditional upon
Sirius access requests by third parties
only if there is a serious excess
request for wholesale services
Vodafone's ego has to open its network
but and because we wanted to avoid kind
of a theoretical a theoretical situation
but as far as we know now there is
serious interest to get access to
photophone Z goes Network which will
improve competition as a final point
what we did is that regulated access to
Vodafone's ago by KP n also a
possibility of course is excluded
because we want to stimulate and
incentivize KP n to compete at an
infrastructure level with Vodafone Z go
everywhere in the country further and
important and lastly an important aspect
of our decision is that we took a light
touch approach to price regulation in
principle ACM will only set prices for
excess when the parties cannot come to
an agreement we do hope that competition
will lead to competitive excess prices
and that we don't have to regulate
prices we are a regulator of lost resort
in our opinion but if it is necessary if
parties cannot come to an agreement we
will step in and set cost based access
prices but only if necessary so finally
wrapping up our wholesale fixed access
decision will lead in our opinion to
improve infrastructure competition
and in the long run it is infrastructure
competition that will push the network's
the boat to networks took and others to
continue to convert to invest in the
Netherlands this should lead to improve
networks and contribute to the best
broadband for everyone now and in the
future so for the next days ladies and
gentlemen while you are on your
conference journey remember that
whatever a session you attend in our
view what is all about is connectivity
and competition thank you very much
[Applause]